[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on parlera nickel demain
rappelez-vous moi si je suis très
content très content même le vendredi
jour de shabbat c'est super j'ai presque
envie de raconter ce qu'on a fait
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait ah oui
cette semaine
exceptionnel on a fait croire à Jordan
Deluxe
Jordan Deluxe mais chez Jordan sur C8 et
on lui a fait croire on allait faire
pendant les vacances de février chez
Sacha
et que voilà et donc Jordan Deluxe il
m'en parle pas tout de suite il devient
ouf il dit à tout le monde ouais mais
truc chez Sacha ses chasseurs il me
prend mon émission donc il m'appelle il
me dit mais c'est quoi cette histoire de
chez Sacha je dis déjà c'est pas du tout
la même émission ça s'appelle toi ça
s'appelle chez Jordan
on va le faire comme ça on inquiétez pas
de temps que je raconte l'histoire et tu
veux rester dans l'émission toi
[Rires]
chez leur daronne quoi
tu vois ça la meuf arrive elle reste là
tranquille
non mais l'autre qui vient bah reviens
reviens Stéphane Eicher là
il est en train de déjeuner en paix on
le péché
[Applaudissements]
pas bon vas-y si vous pouvez faire ça en
silence que je raconte une histoire
j'aimerais juste un tant soit peu faire
mon métier merci donc bonne condition je
demande pas grand-chose je demande juste
de faire mon métier dans de bonnes
conditions c'est tout hein je m'en mets
bon alors voilà bon bah c'est bon donc
on a fait quoi à Jordan donc
Sacha et je lui dis ça rien à voir toi
tu as combien d'invité il me dit un
jubilé il en a deux
attendez et donc Jordan
c'est pas possible je lui dis en plus il
reçoit des gars que tu as jamais connu
il me dit qui je dis Philippe Candeloro
Nelson Monfort
plus ça mais arrête ça n'a rien à voir
avec ce que tu fais et là il m'appelle
et là je lui dis bon je te dis un truc
mais je t'explique tu fermes ta gueule
je dis tu le dis à personne que je vais
dire parce que c'est extrêmement grave
et là je lui dis voilà le président de
la chaîne Franck à Pieto en fait il
vient de découvrir qu'il était fun
histoire
[Rires]
donc là
je dis bon écoute voilà je te le dis moi
je veux te sauver parce que j'adore ce
que tu fais mais là c'est indépendant de
ma volonté donc écoute ce qu'il faut ce
qu'attend bien sûr qu'il nous a fini
parce que je lui dis je lui dis qu'il
faut que tu appelles à piéton et que tu
lui dises que tu trouves quelqu'un de
folle je dans sa famille j'en ai rien à
je lui dis attends il y a pas une
qui part au bureau maintenant et je lui
dis prends une photo de toi avec une qui
part
et en voilà à bientôt et tu lui mets on
est ensemble
[Rires]
on a pris
la photo je l'ai on a pris un panier en
osier
et là et il envoie un gâteau et moi je
préviens Frank abido et Franck à bientôt
lui répond excuse-moi Jordan je ne peux
pas te parler je suis en train de
déjeuner avec le grand rabat de Paris
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
la semaine prochaine
et surtout cyril est rentré direct dans
le jeu il était pas au courant du pied
tout au Lionel Messi le directeur de la
société et tout le monde est au courant
on a lancé un faux communiquer et tout
et Cyril vous avez vous avez oublié un
truc c'est que il l'a envoyé avec moi à
la synagogue de Boulogne
il faut que tu prennes une photo volée
genre tu sors de latina
et là on arrive devant la coque de
Boulogne et la synagogue est fermée et
là il se met limite à pleurer mais elle
est fermée la synagogue
et c'est pas fini je lui dis tu vas
appeler Franck capitaux et dès que tu
l'appelles il faut que tu parles genre
un peu tu vois avec des expressions donc
tu dis comment ça va Franck sur la Torah
je suis contente d'avoir
et donc on a fait des répète au bureau
on a fait des répètes au bureau et donc
on a non franchement sur la Torah je
suis trop tu vas et là de cet été
comment on dit bonjour en juif
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
s
il faut communiquer et tout on a tout
fait il faut communiquer chez Sacha
c'était magnifique et lui dit chez Sacha
mais ça c'est nul en plus tu peux me
faire c'est moi et moi je dis arrête tu
sais très bien qu'il va être nul il va
en faire deux ce sera fini c'est ça
allez voilà on vous raconte les
coulisses la semaine prochaine les
images Cyril rappelez-vous lors de ma
dernière chronique et bien j'avais
décidé de mettre Mathieu Delormeau face
à son hypocrite
[Musique]
de publicité tout ça
ok après mais c'est pas grave les chéris
on vous a parlé de notre ami Jordan de
luxe à l'instant leur série qu'on lui
fait croire que Sacha allait faire son
émission voilà tu sens la nuit regardez
on a fait on avait pas communiquer tous
les samedis dimanche à partir donc
février 9h10 chez Sacha voilà on a mis
le même visuel en plus que chez Jordan
et donc on a fait croire que voilà il
fallait que il porte une kippa et
regardez comme il y a les pâtes qu'il
est pas au bureau regardez la photo
parce qu'ils ont pris la photo de Jordan
de luxe
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Jordan t'inquiète pas Jordan voilà tu
restes bien sûr avec nous mais qu'est-ce
qu'on arrive on en a plus riche et
pleurer moi j'ai pleuré de rien c'est
magnifique très fort l'indique de la
rédac mon chien rappelez-vous Cyril la
semaine dernière pendant ma chronique on
avait mis Mathieu Delormeau face à son
hypocrisie avec Marco Molly puisqu'il le
critiquait dans son dos mais en face il
y avait plus personne je veux vous dire
à tous et là vous allez m'aider il vous
a tous critiqué avant-hier
et le pire chez toi
[Applaudissements]
Mathieu Delormeau avait beaucoup de
dossiers et figurez-vous que les
dossiers tellement gros que Cyril a
préféré envoyer la pub mais j'imagine
que le public a envie de savoir ce qui
s'était passé pendant cette pub
c'était très chaud très tendu pendant la
pub et bien ça tombe bien je suis payé
pour ça
c'est pas vrai
dîner avec un ami et là je sais que tu
as pris mon coeur
esprit de type d'oblige les chroniqueurs
ont voulu calmer le jeu et l'attention
et il part sur Cyril
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez décidé de vous emmêler vous
aussi parce que Mathieu était un peu
trop nerveux à votre goût merci mon cœur
[Musique]
toute la région
[Applaudissements]
donc ça c'était jeudi dernier on passe à
vendredi si je j'ai une question pour
vous qui êtes ami de la langue de
Shakespeare qui écrit les paroles de
l'hymne américain
peut-être en tout cas en tout cas c'est
pas vous Cyril puisque vous avez tenté
une reprise assez approximative de
l'hymne américain et on a voulu traduire
vos paroles traduire ce que vous dites
est-ce que vous parlez très bien anglais
je vous laisse regarder le résultat est
bon
[Musique]
franchement
très beau
on a la chance d'avoir une prof
d'anglais
[Rires]
jamais vos enfants oui bien sûr qui
Benjamin Castaldi leur demanderait de
l'oseille
vous avez bien raison mais il y en a un
autre à qui il faut pas du tout les
confier puisqu'il a une très mauvaise
influence sur les enfants et les ados
c'est Guillaume tonton
ça c'est pas beau sauf qu'il est là et
beaucoup plus fort que Guillaume Genton
et figurez-vous qu'elle a eu Guillaume
Genton elle nous a envoyé sa réaction et
comme dit la date la vérité sort
toujours de la bouche des
Cyril j'ai une petite demande à te faire
s'il te plaît est-ce que quand je fais
l'émission tu pourrais éviter de me
mettre à côté de Guillaume
chroniqueur mais en vérité c'est lui qui
est le plus explosé il s'applique comme
un bolosse et son vernis sur les ongles
c'est vraiment un truc de victime
ça c'est le chroniqueur qui a le la plus
mauvaise influence mais à votre avis
quel est le chroniqueur qui est le plus
lourd autour de cette table
perspicace Cyril perspicace regardez
mais évidemment c'est quoi c'est la
Constitution au nom positive qu'on fait
au dessus de soi le plus lourd
évidemment c'est pas besoin de ma
Castaldi regardez-moi cette lourdeur
pour moi ça c'est licenciement pour
faute grave oui plus on pense que on a
du positif qui va nous arriver
donc positive qu'on fait au dessus de
soi et que plus on pense qu'on est
positif qui va nous arriver
vraiment tout ce qu'il est lourd
[Applaudissements]
Nicolas revient il est affligé
de temps en temps il fait
on passe à l'indice Cyril avec cette
séquence qui a intrigué les
téléspectateurs c'était très furtif à
l'antenne vous avez peut-être entendu
quelque chose donc je vous repasse le
magnéto regardez ou plutôt écouter c'est
quoi elle veut conserver son nouveau-né
Inès devra refaire des injections tous
les ans
s'il vous plaît qu'est-ce que j'ai
entendu là
qu'est-ce que j'ai entendu est-ce qu'on
a tous entendu le même mot ici sur le
plateau vous avez entendu un mois qui
commence par B vous avez entendu ça et
ben oui et bien c'est pas une
hallucination il y a bien eu ce mot
regardez pourquoi si elle veut conserver
son nouveau-né sur moi
[Applaudissements]
pigmentation
l'intervention ne dure que quelques
minutes
en effet n'est pas permanent
qu'est-ce que j'ai entendu là le nez
c'est vrai que c'est le c'est la fin du
visage parce que
[Applaudissements]
ouais
c'est magnifique mais qu'il est cool
on passe à mardi dernier j'ai une
question pour Guillaume Guillaume est-ce
que vous avez quelqu'un dans votre vie
en ce moment oui oui vous êtes en couple
bien sûr si je vous dis royauté et
frisotti ça vous dit quelque chose non
pas du tout connaissez Bertrand lecteur
spécialiste de la royauté à mon avis a
très envie de lui montrer son trône
nos prises de tête
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'autres choses oui cette semaine on a
reçu des danseuses sur le plateau et
elles n'ont pas laissé indifférent tout
le monde parlez de Raymond je sais pas
[Applaudissements]
regardez bien cette danseuse aux cheveux
blonds elle a l'air très sympa bonjour
madame et Cyril je crois que vous avez
remarqué un petit truc perspicace
non il est pas intéressé il a même pas
remarqué c'est pas sa canne de toute
façon vraiment il est focus pas plutôt
focus
[Applaudissements]